si ha sido una reunión que ha comenzado
con una representante de las naciones
unidas- asegurando que de momento no se
han encontrado pruebas sobre esos
agentes químicos esos laboratorios
biológicos en ucrania hemos escuchado a
la representante de eeuu a asegurar que
los únicos laboratorios biológicos que
hay en ucrania son los que se están
utilizando para detectar y para luchar
contra el kobe 19 y de hecho todos nos
estamos beneficiando de ello dice que
esta situación esta reunión que ha
tenido lugar hoy convocada por rusia no
es más que una excusa más un medio para
propagar desinformación información
falsa y ha dicho falsas banderas para
más tarde justificar ataques y temen que
rusia esté preparando dice la embajadora
de eeuu ataques con agentes químicos y
biológicos contra el pueblo ucraniano
rusia por su parte siguen negando que
eso sea verdad dice que ellos no están
mintiendo que aquí quien miente es eeuu
dice que eeuu sin presentar ningún tipo
de pruebas está apoyando laboratorios
biológicos en ucrania donde se están
desarrollando armas biológicas como
insisto de nuevo no ha habido de momento
pruebas que haya presentado y las
naciones unidas han dicho que tampoco lo
han encontrado dice que hay más de 30
laboratorios e insiste en que los que
mienten no son ellos